what is my heart desire vengeance
justice fire and blood
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie you guys
requested a Barris video so I'm going to
explain his history and what it means
for what's happening during season seven
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened so far if you're new to
the channel I do Game of Thrones videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
you guys requested a Varys video so I'll
talk a little bit about his history
especially up in this corner of Essos
and how it's going to inform what's
going on with the Targaryen restoration
and sort of the origins of that in what
it says about what's going on in season
seven in Circe's true downfall which I
think will be money so I'll explain that
because there are a couple of things
that they've confirmed that are coming
back in season seven money is a very big
thing on Game of Thrones and it's all
connected with all these different
factions so let's start with varus's
history first most of his history comes
out on the TV show there are a few small
elements they change but most of his
early history as a child how he was
orphaned how he was cut the sorcerer the
voice that he heard in the blame that's
all right out of the books as a boy I
travelled with the troupe of actors
through the Free Cities one day in mere
a certain man made my master an offer
too tempting to refuse I feared the man
meant to use me as I'd heard some men
used small boys but what he wanted was
far worse he gave me a potion that made
me powerless to move or speak yet did
nothing to dull my senses with a hooked
blade he sliced me root and stem
chanting all the while he burned my
parts in a brazier the flames turned
blue and I heard a voice answer his call
I dream of the voice from the flames was
it a god a demon the conjurer's trick I
don't know that the sorcerer called and
a voice answered there's a little you
don't get from that like his friendship
with Illyrio that goes back to season 1
we'll talk about that in a second but
the important thing to take away from
that sorcerer scene is one you know what
did he see in the flames
who was that sorcerer trying to contact
into he does not forget anything
he will always get what he wants and he
always has plans within plans that he
does
always reveal to everyone else which a
lot of times is a function of his spy
network you can think of them as the
little birds but Cersei has taken a lot
of the little birds in King's Landing
but that doesn't mean that she's
dismantled versus spied Network he goes
all the way to the east
Illyrio is a critical part of that as
well as the Targaryen restoration but
the Targaryen restoration is sort of the
overarching idea the goal that they're
moving towards is not the spy network
itself there are a lot of people that
wonder if Varys might be a black buyer
it's totally possible that he could
share some Targaryen DNA but the way
grand maester pycelle explains it in the
books is that he was born a slave
enlists so his parents died early he
became an orphan and then just started
working with a troop of mummers they
would travel around the Seven Kingdoms
so he got to visit old town he got to
visit King's Landing eventually they
traveled to Mir that's where the
sorcerer bought him from the mummer paid
a high price cut him in an offering to
his God we'll talk about that in a
second too because there's the
implication because it's very similar to
Melisandre with the leeches he might
have been trying to contact the red God
and then just through Varys on the
street so as he narrates his own
backstory he says in order to spite him
I vowed to live cut to this moment here
where his revenge on him is finally
complete although one of the beautiful
things about bears
there's the spider is that he's scary in
a way that a lot of other characters
like the mountain are not scary because
he seems so non-threatening but is so
dangerous so he makes it seem like his
revenge on this sorcerer is going to be
a very very long drawn-out process but
after he'd been thrown on the streets in
mirror he did everything he could to try
and survive he begged he sold his body
eventually he became known as one of the
best pickpockets in the city in Menace
sell sword named Illyrio and that was
the beginning of their friendship the
really funny thing that this led to was
this business arrangement whereby the
awesome pickpocket Varys would go steal
things from wealthy people in Illyrio
who was a little more legit looking
would sell them back to the owners for a
price they became very wealthy and Varys
eventually came to the conclusion that
information was so much more valuable to
people of power so that's how he started
training his network of little mites
they called him little bird
on the TV show but in the books they
were little mice he trained his spy
network eventually the Mad King brings
him on to become his spy master in
eventually recognizing how the Mad King
is going so crazy he starts to formulate
a plan for the Targaryen restoration so
this is where it gets really interesting
in the tourney of Harrenhal
everybody's heard about the famous
tourney of Harrenhal where Rhaegar was
supposedly going to bring the Lords of
the realm under the pretense of a
tournament to advocate for a great
council so they could get rid of the Mad
King Rhaegar would become King and they
could return a sense of normalcy to the
realm put someone on the throne who is
not completely mad Varys a spymaster to
the Mad King alerted him to what was
going on with Attorney of Harrenhal that
was the reason that Aerys attended the
tournament originally he wasn't going to
go
so Varys is slowly pushing the Mad King
over the edge starting to instigate
things that led to Robert's rebellion so
even though it seems like beerus is
working against the realm he's secretly
trying to instigate Robert's rebellion
or at least help it along while he is
still loyal to House Targaryen issues
that he wants to get rid of the Mad King
in a coup is the best engine for a
change so a lot of things happened that
he didn't plan for like the events of
Robert's rebellion and what came after
especially the baby Aegon ray gars young
child there's a lot of conjecture a lot
of unreliable narration because secretly
he's probably going to wind up being a
Blackfyre even if he won't survive to
the end of the story and they're not
even doing him on the TV show so it
sounds kind of complicated but Varys is
just trying to get rid of the Mad King
from the time that he becomes his spy
master to now restore a sense of order
to the realm but all this time I know
there's this mystical element the
sorcerer the voice and the flames in the
background he does know about the White
Walkers he is very learned but for the
most part he's seeking to secure the
realm against potential future threats
so he wants someone on the throne with a
good name who the people love who won't
go completely mad so that's when he
started selling Tyrion and Daenerys at
the beginning of season five with that
speech the interesting thing in all this
though when you get back to Rhaegar
Targaryen his original plan to depose
his father
there's no
mention of Varys working with Rhaegar at
all so it sounds like beerus slowly came
to the conclusion that they needed to
get rid of the Mad King separately from
what Rhaegar was doing so hopefully they
address their relationship during season
seven when beerus is talking to Daenerys
because Barristan Selmy speaks very
fondly of Rhaegar of their time just
hanging out together singing songs
giving money to the poor it paints this
very nice picture of Rhaegar Targaryen
but we've never heard Varys speak of
Rhaegar or any kind of alliance that
they might have had because it sounds
like he was working against him
initially but getting into season 7
stuff so everything is connected pulling
strings from afar even though they made
a couple changes from varus's character
and the things that he does from the
books to the TV show he's a master
planner he knows all the players in the
game and what their strengths and
weaknesses are so it makes sense that
they're bringing Marc Davis's character
tycoon estores back the person from the
iron bank he'll be trying to get his
money back from Cersei money that the
crown owes to the iron bank they're
deeply deeply in debt as of season 1
it's only gotten worse mace Tyrell went
to negotiate better terms on their debt
back during season 5 Cersei does not
seem like she's going to be very
forthcoming you can just imagine her
giving him the brush-off I'll pay you
later you'll get your money when I'm
ready to give you your money she did not
seem the least bit concerned when the
small council tried to raise the issue
of debt oh we owe money go get an
extension on the loan so what does the
iron bank do to people that do not repay
their debts well if ty CONUS Torres is
frustrated during season seven then it's
a perfect opportunity for Varys to sweep
in and suggest Daenerys as somebody who
will replace Cersei and repay the iron
bank what it's do that was Stannis's
whole selling point during season four
so there's this mounting debt that the
crown has the iron bank has already
backed someone else who they think would
repay it which was Stannis he failed so
now the thought is that they would move
on to someone else so just as beerus was
an important part of the downfall of the
Mad King remember he pushed him to the
tourney at Harrenhal instigated a lot of
events which then led to Rhaegar
stealing away with Liana all spilling
into the chaos of Robert's rebellion he
is also in
her mental part of deposing Circe so he
is the former of alliances the maker of
plans dragons are very physical very
immediate threat to Circe but Varys is
the true threat because he can shift
alliances on a dime so money is just as
instrumental in Circe's downfall as
taking a dragon to the face or the
valonqar or any other physical way that
she might end up dying during the story
let me know in the comments what do you
think that bears his role is going to be
during season 7 because he's already
forged all of Daenerys his alliances he
might have to broker one more with the
Starks so even though Daenerys has this
large army behind her there's still so
much left for him to do so leave all
your requests for new Game of Thrones
videos in the comments below I'll say
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner d1 please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video what
you wait for my next video you can click
here for all the Star Wars trailers I've
been posting and you can click here for
all the Game of Thrones promos thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you